What’s the next element?
Hassium. I know nothing about hassium, shall
we make something up?
Hassium is an element which I knew nothing
about. But now I discover it’s much more
interesting than I thought. We’re here in
the German state of Hesse at the institute
GSI were hassium was first made in 1984. Hassia
is the Latin name for this part of Germany
Hesse and hence it is named after the place
it was discovered. So down here we have the
accelerator that accelerated atoms of iron
to bang into a lead target to make element
108 Hassium. Element 108 is actually in the
same group of the periodic table as iron,
that much I knew when I first talked about
it. But what I didn’t realise is that the
element has a few atoms that are long enough
lived that you can really do chemistry. So
once the atom flies off from the back of the
target when it has been created you can pass
it through an atmosphere of oxygen and make
the oxide hassium tetroxide Hs04. And the
iron of this molecule, this oxide can then
be followed to see how volatile it is and
compared with osmium tetroxide. Osmium tetroxide
is a white solid which is quite volatile,
it easily evaporates and you can show that
hassium tetroxide does not evaporate quite
so easily. But it’s amazing this is an element
only forty atoms have been made but you can
tell how its oxide behaves. Osmium has one
of the highest melting points of any element
that’s known. The people who make periodic
tables where you have a sample of each element
have great trouble melting osmium to make
a sample, so it may be that hassium would
have an even higher melting point, it could
be that it’s the highest melting point in
the periodic table. But one would have to
make a lot more atoms than that if you were
going to find out what the melting point was.
I think people may be able to calculate it,
but the melting point depends on the strength
of the interaction between the atoms and unless
you have quite a few atoms that’s very difficult
to measure. And quite a few means many tens
of millions because even a small particle,
a so called nanoparticle, of metal can have
quite different properties from a large lump.